voilà c'est le temps de passer à notre
de second et dernier débat alors être
ancien ministre c'est s'asseoir à
l'arrière d'une voiture et s'apercevoir
qu'elle ne démarre pas à cette petite
phrase avait valu à françois goulard
ancien ministre des gouvernements
raffarin et villepin le prix de l'humour
politique
mais voilà quitté la vie publique dans
les faits ben c'est pas toujours aussi
drôle lors des dernières élections
législatives 302 députés sortants ne se
sont pas ont été battus ou ne se sont
pas représentés et est-ce qu'il ya une
vie après la politique eh ben c'est la
question qu'on va trancher après ce
reportage de hull jonathan du président
c'est un revers électoral qui a fait
beaucoup parler de lui manuel valls
devenu macro nist n'a pas passé le tamis
des dernières législatives l'ancien
premier ministre de françois hollande a
été sorti dès le premier tour du scrutin
dans une circonscription des français de
l'étranger sans préciser son avenir il
s'est retiré des réseaux sociaux
laconique adieu twitter d'autres poids
lourds du camp présidentiel ont été
sèchement battus aux législatives
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner dans les
alpes-de-haute-provence bien obligés
depuis la défaite de s'écarter du jeu
politique national faut regarder dans
cette position ici donc la gauche est
donc ici la droite idem pour richard
ferrand l'ancien président de
l'assemblée nationale a chuté du siège
où il était perché ce très proche des
manuels macron n'a pas été reconduit
dans son fief du finistère selon
l'opinion il aurait même refusé
d'intégrer le gouvernement d'elisabeth
bornes rien à 2 puis filtrer sur ses
ambitions sa dernière prise de parole
la voici je veux évidemment dressé mes
félicitations à celle qui l'emporté ce
soir est formé pour rêver pour la france
et pour notre territoire des voeux de
plein succès si ces échecs son
retentissant ils ne sont pas morts
politiquement pour autant selon la
communicante emilie zapolsky on s'y
attendait pas du tout en fait qu'ils
soient mises en échec comme ça au
législatif ça a été assez flagrant
sanitaires ça a été une gifle quand même
assez forte mais je pense qu'ils ont la
possibilité de remonter la pente parce
qu'ils ont existé auparavant en termes
politiques et de manière très importante
encore une fois autour des en 2017
benoît hamon candidat socialiste dépasse
à peine les 6 % des voix la gauche n'est
pas mort vous me l'avez dit vous
attendez une renaissance ce soir elle
est douloureuse malgré le lancement de
son mouvement générations il finira par
se retirer de la vie politique en 2021
l'échec de 2017 l'aura marqué au fer
rouge
salut
d'autres à l'image de cécile duflot sont
parvenus à rebondir l'ancienne ministre
du logement qui espéraient l'investiture
écologiste en 2017 ce sera cassé les
dents à la primaire e élevé battu au
premier tour elle dirige désormais la
branche française de l'eau entre oxfam
une porte de sortie qui semble cohérente
au vu de son parcours
y at il une vie après la politique on en
parle ce soir avec mes invités jeannette
bougrab bonsoir vous laisser is docteur
en droit public aujourd'hui conseillère
d'état et la politique vous l'avez bien
connu de près à lui même prix vous êtes
engagé et puis dans le gouvernement
fillon vous avez été secrétaire d'état à
la jeunesse et la vie associative de
2017 2012 et puis la politique vous
l'avez quittée j'accueille à vos côtés
jérôme lavrilleux ancien député européen
ancien directeur de cabinet de jean
françois copé ancien directeur adjoint
de la campagne de nicolas sarkozy en
2012 est aujourd'hui conseiller
politique après une mise au vert qui a
duré trois ans
nous on nous a raconté j'accueille
également par écran interposé razzy
hammadi ancien député socialiste de
seine-saint-denis vous êtes aujourd'hui
à la tête d'un média spécialisé sur les
problématiques urbaines newstand cities
que vous avez fondé vous êtes directeur
pédagogique de du nba management des
transitions urbaine à l'institut léonard
de vinci vous allez publier en octobre
un livre sur les dix défis urbains bref
ça fait un soleil très garni comme quoi
on peut quitter la politique et et faire
complètement autre chose henri vernet
bonsoir vous êtes rédacteur en
chef-adjoint parisien aujourd'hui en
france un des plus fins connaisseurs de
la scène politique française et vous
avez publié avec votre confrère renaud
dély tous les coups sont permis et
frères ennemis l'hyper violence en
politique chez calmann lévy et puis bien
sûr guillaume dingue c'est rester et qui
restera et interviendra jusqu'à la fin
de cette émission je voudrais pas
recommencer en nous interpellant sur le
jour où vous avez quitté la politique et
on peut commencer par vous razzy hammadi
parce que parfois la politique on la
quitte parfois c'est elle qui vous
quittent pour vous est ce que c'est
votre défaite au soir du premier tour
des législatives en 2017 qui est signé
l'arrêt de votre parcours politique
razzy hammadi
le quinquennat auquel j'ai participé en
tant que député qui était le cas
hollande est très éprouvant pour de
nombreuses raisons en même temps
lorsqu'on a le parcours que l'on a
lorsqu'on s'est engagé depuis des années
on a le cuir un petit peu tanné mais non
je pense que la politique dans ma tête
s'est arrêtée le jour où j'ai décidé de
passer le concours d'entrée à à l'essec
et c'était pendant mon mandat
parlementaire c'est à dire que
avant même le premier tour j'avais passé
ce test d'entrée est donc dans ma tête
j'étais déjà un peu ailleurs
vous avez déjà pris votre décision
jeannette bougrab vous vous souvenez
d'un jour vous êtes dit j'arrête
oui parce qu'en réalité cantine une
femme les questions se posent un moment
de la maternité voilà et
j'ai une
ma maternité est un peu différente des
autres parce que j'ai décidé d'adopter
quand vous décidé d'adopter que vous
êtes une femme seule la compatibilité de
la vie politique ou ch 24 ou des
paddocks n ya pas de vacances et on vous
demande des déplacements je m'étais
engagé au moment de la procédure
d'agrément de mon adoption de me retirer
de la vie politique après après 2012
pour avoir un bébé d'accord jérôme
lavrilleux vous n'avez été longtemps un
visage des coulisses de la politique
puisque vous avez été notamment en en
rond le préciser a travaillé très proche
de jean françois copé le grand public
vous êtes découvert à l'occasion de la
sphère bygmalion qui vous a valu d'être
condamné l'an dernier à trois ans de
prison dont un avec sursis pour
financement illégal de campagne une
condamnation dont vous avez fait appel
je le précise mais dès 2019 après
quelques trois décennies d'engagement
vous avez décidé d'une certaine façon de
partir en dordogne pour ouvrir un gîte
raconte est vrai alors c'est un petit
peu compliqué parce que moi ma vie
politique réellement même si j'ai été
député européen mais députée europe 1
vous êtes à bruxelles vous êtes loin
public sénat donc personne s'y intéresse
vraiment moi je chez
le patient soit la chose la plus
intelligente que j'ai fait de ma vie
mais je n'ai pas à une bêtise près
ma vie politique s'est arrêtée
brutalement le 26 mai 2014 dans les
faits c'est quand je vais sur bfm tv que
et que le grand public vous découperez
voilà vous ratez donc ma vie bascule en
moins d'un quart d'heure de l'anonymat à
peu près complet à part aussi me
connaissiez sinon personne ne me
connaissait et mon corps défendant je
bascule dans une hyper violent c'est
hyper médiatisation
en même temps puisqu'on rappelle au
grand public un qui n'était à l'époque
question dans cette affaire bygmalion du
dérapage des comptes de campagne de
nicolas sarkozy c'est pas ça à l'époque
il était question de dire que j'avais
détourné de l'argent à mon profit
personnel et il a fallu que ça quitte la
sphère bygmalion pour devenir l' affaire
des comptes de campagne de nicolas
sarkozy ça m'a pris cinq ans pour
travailler à rétablir la vérité ce qui a
d'ailleurs été dit et confirmé au
premier jugement que vous avez eue mais
en attendant
voilà alors on va pas ici refaire la
ferme du mas lyon c'est pas le sujet
mais du coup quand vous partez en
dordogne ouvrir un gîte je vous dit
j'arrête tout
en fait à l'été 2014 je ne sais pas si
je vais rester député européen longtemps
ou pas je m'attends dans ma tête je me
dis ils vont me foute en prison il
couper la tête assez rapidement au sens
figuré du terme mais quand je me dis et
si ça s'arrête moi j'ai pas de plan b je
suis pas héritier je n'ai pas d'argent
de côté et je n'ai il faut que je fasse
autre chose c'est un autodidacte de la
politique donc je
me dis que bunge ouvrir des gîtes
d'accord avec l'aide de mes parents
j'achète un corps de ferme dans le
périgord vert c'est la partie la moins
touristique de la dordogne et puis
tant que je suis député européen chaque
week end et disponibles chaque vacance
de disponible je charge le camion de mon
père et je descends de saint-quentin je
fais un aller-retour en trois jours pour
faire des travaux est-ce que j'ai pas
les moyens de faire faire par quelqu'un
d'autre c'est tout l'argent que je gagne
par dans mes frais de justice
et donc quand je quitte mon mandat de
député européen en 2010 9 après avoir
essayé des d'honorer ce mandat en
terminant que à ses deuxièmes députés
sur 751 et bien je deviens je continue
parce que j'ai marqué sur mon site sur
mon compte twitter j'étais homme de
ménage et longtemps été payés pour faire
ménage après certains élus et maintenant
je le fais au sens propre dans notre
mire de la terre dans notre rythme on
regardait ce qu'est les départs heureux
de la vie politique je peins pas des
départs en retraite 1 / heureux non
c'est assez rare c'est vrai que la
plupart du temps c'est subi en réalité
quand on commence une carrière politique
au fond chacun d'eux j'imagine se voit
au sommet c'est à dire que la politique
en france a été extrêmement pyramidale
je me souviens d'ailleurs dans les deux
enquêtes dans les deux livres que nous
avions commis avec renaud dély un jour
c'est un témoignage d'un député sur la
concurrence c'était bien le look mais
qui citait sarkozy et sarkozy devaient
expliquer un jour où le luxe interrogés
pourri on lui proposait un secrétariat
d'état alors il hésite un peu ça n'est
pas tout il demande conseil hélas
sarkozy lui a répondu mais écoute tu te
pose même pas la question la vie
politique en france est unique et rami
il ya plusieurs étages à la base il ya
les maires les élus locaux etc et puis
il ya les députés et au sommet tout au
sommet les chefs des tables et juste
avant il ya les ministres et donc quel
que soit le poste qu'on te propose
ministre des choux farcis tu prends les
chauffards 6 et une carrière politique
une ambition politique c'est un peu ça
c'est à dire que quel que soit le mandat
que vous décrochez au fond vous pensez
déjà graal suprême alors évidemment tout
le monde n'a ni l'envoi
par définition néanmois cette ambition
elle est là et donc à départ qui arrive
avant un aboutissement de carrière en
tout cas un accomplissement pour soi
donc ça peut être un député ça peut être
maire d'une grande ville mais tant qu'on
n'a pas au moins accompli cela ça peut
pas être un départ heureux et c'est
toujours vécu comme un
déclic comme ça voilà donc du coup on a
une chance c'était une exception
oui j'ai toujours été un petit peu parce
que j'ai un petit bleu dans le futur est
un peu timide mais non moi je fais la
chance de d'abord de de rentrer dans la
politique sans avoir été une militante
jeunes rpr ex terrain on m'avait repéré
parce que j'étais maître de conférences
en droit public assure bonne car maso
m'avait identifiées donc on me pousse
etc je vais dans les gêner législatives
dont je ne voulais par elle dans le
xviiie arrondissement à barbès entre
barbès et château rouge donc j'avais
aucune chance mais on y va quand même et
puis après après je sors et on reviens
me chercher mais mais de dire d'avoir
cette ambition là je la trouve presque
malsaine en fait c'est à dire que se
dire que l'ambition d'un politique c'est
d'accéder au pouvoir suprême sans se
dire qu'on fait de la politique pour
l'intérêt général je trouve ça malsain
voilà on n'exclut pas l'autre non je
reconnais mais être rongés par
mission parce qu'on est forcément de la
politique malheureuse on est forcément
malheureux quand on fait la politique
l'ambition peut être un moteur oui mais
veut face et connaître l'avis des partis
politiques à une forme de très grande
ingratitude et il faut quand même validé
c'est pas des couleuvres c'est des
anacondas pendant et donc du coup il
savoir en fait voilà moi j'ai les
cheveux je ne garde plutôt un bon
souvenir de cette période razzy hammadi
concrètement qu'est ce qui se passe
quand on est battu le téléphone sonne
plus les députés ont droit au chômage
alors il ya peut-être insu un point
auquel je voudrais revenir suite aux
propos d'henri vernet il a totalement
raison
au sens où ce soit pour de bonnes ou de
mauvaises raisons des raisons de service
à l'intérêt général qui me motive ou
d'ambition c'est vrai que on se dit bon
c'était mon cas j'étais parlementaire
rapporteur général de textes donc à
plusieurs reprises on m'annonce au
gouvernement sur des sujets que je
collais sur lesquels je travaille depuis
des années puisqu'il ya aussi quelque
chose qui est très important c'est le
parcours des uns et des autres avant
d'être élu puisque c'est aussi votre
sujet moi j'ai jamais travaillé dans
dans le public ou dans la politique ce
qui n'est pas une mauvaise chose en soi
c'était un parcours différent c'est ce
que j'ai souhaité et au moment où je
suis élue députée
c'est un moment où je décide de partir à
l'étranger dans le cadre de ma vie
professionnelle et c'est un peu
finalement au moment où je le souhaitais
le moins que j'ai la chance de pouvoir
être candidat alors que je courrais
derrière ça depuis des années et c'est
vrai que lorsque j'apprends à 3 après
trois reprises mahjoub inacio
gouvernement qui finalement ne se fait
pas pour des raisons que je n'ai jamais
su mais parce qu'il y avait une
méritocratie qui à mon avis devaient
être respectés qui ne l'a pas été c'est
la vie c'est vrai que la jeune fille bon
j'ai fait le job on a bossé était dans
les trois députés les plus présents les
plus efficaces au nombre d'amendements
et c'est la commission des finances jour
et nuit il y avait une sorte de plafond
de verre pas au sens où longtemps
lorsqu'on débat des discriminations mais
un plafond de verre au sens de jeu le ma
complice et plus dans ce cadre là et je
ne me voyais pas durer pour durer
combien ça se passe ensuite je pense
qu'il vaut mieux le choisir que le subir
mais il ya aussi quelque chose que je
voudrais dire par rapport à la question
que vous posez et suite à ce que disait
monsieur vernet précédemment c'est que
générationnel mans les choses ont changé
aussi ce ne serait ce que pour des
raisons biologiques c'est à dire que la
vie active aujourd'hui à la 50 60 70 ans
donc avant on faisait de la politique à
partir de à part pour quelques
personnalités mais on commençait la
politique à 45 50 55 ans une fois que
vous l'avez fait sa vie professionnelle
on était médecin enseignant où on est
gagné les cantonales qui ont dirigé le
conseil général où on était envoyé ici
ou là grosso modo la vie politique était
la fin de la vie active où elle était
toute la vie active or quand vous avez
des profils tels que le mien vous êtes
élu à 32 ans une jeune députée de la
majorité vous avez quoi comme solution
soit dès le début vous vous dites je ne
vais pas faire de la politique toute ma
vie et donc vous vivez avec et ça fait
partie de votre plan de carrière et donc
c'est moins choquant c'est moins brutal
soit vous dites ah ben je vais faire que
ça et là je trouve que là ça devient
malsain ce que j'ai vu des collègues des
amis un continuer à s'accrocher
jusqu'à s'abîmer donc comment ça se
passe mais ça se passe très
tranquillement j'ai eu un petit peu mois
de la chance puisque j'ai passé un an
aux états unis tout de suite après mon
mandat parlementaire donc la coupure a
été totale et
je pense et je terminerai là dessus ces
camps politiques
peut-être
peut-être plus monsieur lavrilleux que
jamais debout grave mais quelquefois on
a l'impression aussi d'être un petit peu
dans une prison mentale dire que tout
est très important vous êtes le coeur de
la planète vous êtes chaque sujet
attention faut pas rater cette réunion
demain matin à 9h sinon le sinon les
tours s'effondrent c'est alors que on
s'en fout en fait dans l'absolu oui
c'est important mais à l'extérieur il se
passe aussi des choses même du point de
vue de la réflexion de fond - dans le
domaine de l'urbanisme et de
l'aménagement dans lequel je travaille
et madame tricot précédemment juste
avant on a aussi des appareils et une
vie politique qui s'est vidée de sa
substance en termes de pertinence sur le
débat politique et sur le débat
d'experts alors j'ai en avrieux vous
nous l'avait confié vous êtes un
autodidacte est ce que c'est une bonne
école la politique d'être autodidacte
nom est ce que c'est ce que quand on est
autodidacte est ce que est ce que la
politique c'est une bonne école de
formation est ce que ça puisque comme le
dit razzy hammadi ont fini par perdre un
peu le sens de réaliser que toute
étreinte rsa d'un ford en jeu c'est
toujours très prétentieux de dire ça
j'ai jamais perdu le sens des réalités
je toujours rentrer chez moi on m'a
toujours considéré ça m'est arrivé
d'être conduit par un chauffeur est
qu'un pin pon et traverser paris toute
vitesse se met même arrivé est
malheureusement trop souvent deux fois
de rentrer de meetings et nicolas
sarkozy dans un an dans un jet j'étais
pas programmé pour faire je touche mais
je vous assure quand je rentrais chez
moi je m'occupais de mon linge je
m'occupais de faire mes courses j'avais
personne pour le faire et je me
retrouvais tout comme un conte tout seul
parce que vous consacrez 24 heures sur
24 à la politique vous couper de tout
autre relationnel c'est là où c est ça
finisse est vrai par être une drogue
quand on débranche la perfusion ah ben
ça fait mal
c'est pas le même parcours mais mais ça
oui oui c'est du jeu oui mais moi moi
les deux retraits de la perfusion a été
assez brutales il ya eu quelques
hématomes sur le sur le sujet mais après
je pensais que j'en étais totalement
remis et ça vite pas de temps en temps
d'essayer de replonger en politique non
mais enfin sincèrement sur la moi j'en
ai pris plein la figure mais il
n'empêche que moi je demeure convaincu
que si l'on veut changer des choses ça
passe nécessairement par la vie
politique en conjugue plus d'avant
dernier rang protocolaire sur le plan
gouvernemental
j'ai jamais été élu j'ai été battu
royalement dans le xviiie contre et donc
mais en même temps j'avais appris j'ai
rencontré de la possibilité de bouger
les choses avec on a fait un rapport sur
le suicide des enfants c'est un sujet
dont personne ne veut aborder le mal
être aujourd'hui on parle des malades
des adolescents mais vous savez qu'à des
gosses de 8 ans qui se jette par la
fenêtre qui se défenestre on a eu la
chaire eu la chance de travailler boris
cyrulnik on l'a fait des coûts
effectivement parce qu'il fallait faire
attention de ne pas être en
interministériel de pas demandé m
j'avais obtenu l'accord de françois
fillon mais ma tutelle le ministre
l'éducation ne voulait pas en entendre
parler parce que ça pouvait remettre en
cause j'ai travaillé avec israël nisand
sur les grossesses précoces on a fait
des choses formidables vont s'occuper
des quartiers personne ne voulait s'en
occuper parce que une partie du
gouvernement disait mais c'est pas notre
électorat donc on aller dans les
quartiers le 31 décembre et bans avec
des voitures brûlaient on était sur le
terrain donc de dire que moi j'ai pas
fait de syndicats étudiants mais je
crois que rama yade
vous aviez fait du militants arabes
était pas trompé voilà donc moi j'ai pas
fait tout ça donc urgent écoles du
village
et et je suis une fille de jim de harkis
qui a fait ses études de droit qui
travaillent pendant ses études et je
n'ai jamais regardé au delà tant que je
n'avais pas eu mon poste de à la fac
parce que je savais très bien qu'il
fallait d'abord s'assurer les fins de
mois la très grande liberté c'est quand
on ne dépend pas financièrement et de la
politique en fait voilà mais ça veut pas
dire qu on le fait en dilettante c'est
pas vrai mais et le sacrifice que l'on
fait quand on est femme mais c'est pas
un sacrifice parce que c'est de devoir
s'arrêter quand on veut effectivement
avoir une famille voilà et ça on le dit
pas assez au passage faut l'expliquer
aussi au grand public
sacerdoce les coups de soirées beaucoup
de week end passé aux cons ça c'est plus
facile pour les hommes parce qu'ils ont
une épouse ils ont parfois voilà il
laisse les enfin la maison mais quand
vous êtes une femme c'est un peu
différent henry en juin dernier deux
députés sur dix ont pas souhaité se
représenter est ce que ce chiffre vous
étonne non parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
une espèce de dévalorisation de la
politique d'abord soin qu'il ya le
sentiment que la marge de manoeuvre
du politique et singulièrement du député
dans 5 à un public alors en même temps
il se trouve que justement là il ya une
opportunité historique pour que voilà le
soudan parlementaire revient un peu au
centre du jeu d'ailleurs on voit bien
que se joue actuellement une espèce de
bataille entre l'elysée et l'assemblée à
qui va récupérer un peu de pouvoir et ça
ça paraît presque une anomalie dans
notre système de la 5ème république dont
peut-être qu'ils ont choisi le mauvais
moment pour le coc pour ne pas se
représenter mais sinon non de manière
générale c'est pas très étonnant parce
que je me souviens justement aussi dans
le cadre de ces enquêtes avoir eu des
discussions à ce sujet avec michel
rocard on lui avait demandé mais qu'est
ce qu est ce que vous regrettez quelque
chose dans votre vie publique et ils
nous avaient dit non parce que comme
premier ministre finalement j'ai pu
réformer dans le laps de temps assez
court qu'il a eues dans le deuxième set
et n'a de mitterrand il a pu faire pas
mal de réforme et il considère avoir agi
finalement à peu près comme un président
dans la mesure où de toute façon avec la
complexification des problèmes avec la
mondialisation de toute façon la marge
de manoeuvre la marge d'action des
pouvoirs politiques se réduit énormément
déjà cause est aux manettes donc que les
députés soient un petit peu déçue de ce
pas mais ça touche également les
ministres rappelez-vous le mal qu'a eue
mails macron afin d'abord à trouver un
ou une première ministre puisque
certains et certaines ont décliné le
poste je veux dire c'était inimaginable
et 10 ou 15 ans de roulage et mais vu du
danger
jamais je veux dire la boxe c'est dire à
quel point c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
cette fonction là elle n'est plus aussi
valoir parce que vous parliez des pin
pon vous parliez de tous les avantages
puisque on trimballe oui c'est
anecdotique mais c'est vrai que pendant
des décennies on a bien vécu en faisant
de la politique aujourd'hui bas vous
risquez quand même des mises en examen
c'est d'ailleurs votre cas vous risquez
des condamnations vous risquez le même
d'aller en prison il est comment dire
des cons sont extrêmement contrôlée et
ça tant mieux je veux dire on a voulu
cet espace est aussi une violence
physique c'est une violence moi j'ai été
menacé de mort à plusieurs reprises mais
me parles et écris moi je me souviens
puisqu'on on s'était vus de niort pour
l'aider je me souviens de ce qu'on met d
expliquer un jour quand on vous a dit
que vous a dit les gens comme vous il
extrait sans vous n'avez choqué parce
qu'on avait parlé bien sûr c est
évidemment parce que moi j'ai été
compliqué j'étais convoqué à matignon
quand j'avais dit moubarak doit partir
au moment du printemps arabe ont maudit
mais lors les gens comme vous on les
contrôle pas donc des gens comme vous
c'était des gens issus de l'immigration
françois fillon qui vous disent non
c'est pas françois fillon s'était pas
françois fillon et frais non et les gens
ont faim mais sincèrement s'est toujours
très bien comporté avec moi mais est le
nouveau sauveur ans non non le corps
c'était claude guéant c'était claude
guéant qui m'avait dit on m'appelle je
réponds quoi mais ce que ça me rend fier
on avait souffert mais j'en ai souffert
mais enfin si j'en ai souffert sans
doute sur le moment mais l'avantagé ou
l'inconvénient ouallal j'ai vécu des
violences sans sans commune mesure
depuis l'enfance je connais des propos
racistes de à châteauroux donc moi
délégués des ligues dès le cours
préparatoire je savais ce qu'on disait
melon biko etc ces gens là
l'expression qui est tenu par la
ministre aujourd'hui démène de macron
combien de fois moins qu'un entendu en
dira pas si les gens comme si les jeux
si les autres étaient comme vous et
c'est donc cette violence là moi je la
connais et je connaîtrai toujours là
pardon j'avais programmé n'est pas
spécifique au monde années 50 elle émane
d'un racisme oui
oui mais elle est le monde moi j'en
discutais en aparté tout à l'heure c'est
à dire que je suis toujours étiqueté
nicolas sarkozy et on faisait une
réflexion en disant ah bah oui toi tu
étais avec nicolas sarkozy tel pour le
karcher mais je dis mais où les gens
vont chercher des trucs pareils et c'est
comme ça donc je paye d'une certaine
manière entre guillemets mon
appartenance à un gouvernement parce
qu'il y aura toujours une suspicion qui
posera sur moi une forme voilà et c'est
ça qui est extrêmement difficile parce
qu'en réalité on est entre parenthèses
sa vie personnelle on entre parenthèses
plein chose vous êtes attaqués sur les
mains norman les réseaux sociaux on vous
menace mes parents recevaient des
lettres on l'est on les a joués c'est
monstrueux je m'en veux d'avoir fait
subir ça mes parents aujourd'hui on me
dirait bas il faut se réengager on me
l'a proposé mais généreux déclinés j'ai
décliné pour protéger les miens jérôme
lavrilleux la violence en politique vous
l'avais touché de près je me souviens
d'une interview au cous avait accordé à
l'ops vous avez dit que déclariez il
m'arrive d'avoir peur je dis à mes
proches que si un jour j'avais un
accident de voiture il faudrait faire
une expertise je n'ai pas envie
d'apprendre à nager dans 20 cm d'eau
comme robert boulin alors appel à nos
plus jeunes téléspectateurs que robert
boulin simplement du ministre du travail
de valéry giscard d'estaing qui avait
été retrouvée effectivement mort dans un
étang en 20 cm d'eau mais
ce que j'ai raison pas de le ressentir
comme ça c'est le ressenti j'avais vous
aviez peur pour votre vie
je pense que celui qui était le plus
dangereux pour sa vie c'était moi c'est
triste mais j'ai essayé de surmonter ça
j'ai appris à faire semblant d'être
heureux mais je pense qu'on sort mais
jamais mais il ya des gens qui parlent
d'un grand public moi j'ai jamais eu de
problème les gens ou ne reconnaissent
pas ou quand ils me reconnaissent et les
français adorent la politique adore tout
ça ils vont me disait vous payer pour
les autres vous aviez peur au sein de
votre famille politique
au sein de ma famille politique
tellement d'intérêt qui sont en jeu est
tellement d'avenir de tellement
personnes qui sont en jeu n'est parfois
même les gens qui sont hélés pour le
compte d'autres savaient j'habitais dans
un hameau 15 km de saint quentin
on ne pouvait pas aller chez moi c'est
un cul de sac un mot un cul de sac c'est
à dire vraiment la roche-chalais
vulgaire mais le trou du monde pouvait
pas y aller pas ils n'ont jamais vu un
véhicule 75
j'ai eu une période où ça faisait
régulièrement
mais quand vous approchez les gens se
bat à mais l'autre violence elle vient
de tout le monde vous savez quand éclate
cette affaire mon père il avait à
l'époque soixante dix ans 73 ans il des
gens vont chercher mon père mais je suis
pas sur liste rouge pour pertes et pas
sur l'histoire ou la vitesse d'un
quentin une journaliste
célèbre radio tient logo rouge frappe à
la porte de mon père mon père paul il
ouvre la porte en le micro sur
lavrilleux ça fait quoi d'être le père
d'un voyou
à vous imaginer la violence pour la
famille enfin vous vous mettez à la
place des gens vous rendez compte que
journaliste pas méchant n'ai pas envie
de blesser et l'urgence qui amène sa
aucun recul
or aucun tir mais peut-être que la
salade qu'on nous vend est pas
totalement celle là est ce qu'on peut se
poser des questions et vous prenez ça le
pire pour moi c'était pas la violence
des coups tordus j'en ai fait un j'ai
été violent avec des gens et des
adversaires j'ai rédiger des
argumentaires violent je pouvais
l'assumé mais
j'avais de la famille j'ai une chance
inouïe la vie est ainsi faite que
j'avais divorcé il ya longtemps j'ai pas
lésés ggg par emmener mon couple et mes
enfants dans dans un truc qui était
ingérable à l'époque heureusement
j'étais tout seul mais j'ai mes parents
ma soeur mon frère quand vous prenez la
une de votre jeu quotidien local qui dit
parce que votre soeur à un restaurant
que les services vétérinaires vont
débarquer il ya un article d'une page là
dessus sont jamais débarqué pour faire
fermer le restaurant de ma soeur et et
vous vous dites et c'est de ma faute
tout ça pour ça disent pas c'est la
faute du compte y écrit l'article je
vous dis c'est ma faute à moi c'est moi
qui suis en train de danser d'une
violence extrême et je me plains pas je
on va dire la vrillette encore en train
de se calmer je vous raconte ce qui
s'est passé sur aviez participé aussi en
revanche a titre perso général jamais
rasé les murs quand un journaliste est
venu pour m'interviewer j'ai expliqué et
réexpliqué réexpliqué je prends le tgv
j'explique aux contrôleurs 10 ans après
je vais m'acheter des chaussures rue de
rennes parce que je voulais avoir des
chaussures pour revenir à l'assemblée
nationale ça fait longtemps que je mets
plus de chaussures de costumes et la
dame elle lui dit vous êtes sur notre
fichier je dis oui alors je dis
d'avrillé est lavé eric attias celui qui
est connu
dois je vous adore fut fans je n'y a pas
de raison d'être femme d'accord mais
c'est la violence de plus pouvoir être
anonyme si on souhaite à nous d être
anonyme mais les gens sont toujours bien
comportés les particuliers rasé m'a dit
jérôme lavrilleux faisait allusion à la
rédaction d'argumentaire de deux petites
phrases vous dans mon souvenir et
l'époque où elle était chargée de la
riposte au parti socialiste est-ce qu'on
se laisse parfois enivré par une forme
de violence verbale de recherche du bon
mode attaque qui fait mal
je pense que c'est c'est une question de
tempérament
je me rappelle depuis on est
devenu assez proche avec un certain
nombre de pas de porte parole à l'époque
qui était qui était à l'ump qui
aujourd'hui agissent dans le domaine
plutôt professionnel privé
mais il ya le jeu d'estrade d'accord il
ya le jeu d'estrade de l'argumentaire de
hockey et ensuite il ya le fait de
ne pas respecter un certain nombre de
règles moi je me suis toujours astreints
à une sorte de code d'honneur hier de
pas ne pas attaquer sur des choses qui
font mal et ça m'a plutôt bien servi
puisque j'ai toujours eu de très bonnes
relations y compris avec les gens
auxquels j'ai pu être opposés
politiquement et avec lesquels
aujourd'hui j'ai aussi de très très
bonnes relations ces violences
la violence du monde politique vous
l'avez pas vous les papes 6 6 à 6,6 très
clairement alors moi je les plus connus
au niveau entre guillemets au niveau
local puisque à la limite au niveau
parlementaire c'est tous les cinq ans et
une élection vous avez le combat
politique entre les parties au niveau
national le jeu de l'opposition ou
lorsque vous faisait dans la majorité
bien donc mais au niveau local la par
rapport à ce que disait jérôme
lavrilleux vous touchez véritablement un
certain intérêt puisque vous avez des
gens qui qui concrètement depuis des
années vive et ne peuvent vivre et
d'être salarié que par la politique
c'est à dire que là vous parlez des
parlementaires des ministres mais nous
avons aussi un certain nombre d'élus
locaux dont certains sont pas forcément
maire son adjoint à côté sont élus à la
communauté d'agglo et ça fait 25 30 ans
il n'y a rien d'autre et là ils sont
certaines fois certains dans certains
cas ils sont prêts à tout pour défendre
ça parce que ça n'est plus une question
de gauche de droite ou d'idées c'est une
question de survie sociale économique
donc moi j'ai coutume de dire qu'il ya
un duo qui pour moi peut aussi justifier
ou expliquer un certain mal être par
rapport à ce que vous disiez sur un
certain nombre de gens qui veulent plus
faire de la politique c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on propose à des gens
d'être ministre sinon je veux pas être
ministre voulait être premier ministre
l'enjeu alors je veux pas être premier
ministre c'est ce couple c'est la
méritocratie et la médiocratie c'est à
dire que à partir du moment où il
s'est dans le privé au quotidien vous
avez commencé on était trois salariés
aujourd'hui on est une vingtaine
est ce que vous voulez dire un dvd
quand vous dites médiocratie c'est
médiocrité ou la médiacratie les médias
non médiocrité la médiocrité c'est à
dire qu'à partir du moment où vous avez
des gens qui aiment ce qu'ils font
qu'ils sont prêts à tout donner pour
leur pays au delà des clivages
politiques pour l'intérêt général et ces
gens-là dix bombes et je me bats c'est
bon
si pour ce niveau de rémunération cette
violence les sacrifices que je fais je
veux bien la passion tout ce qu'on veut
les idées les valeurs
pas au prix de ma santé paho prix de de
la sécurité de ma famille oui à un
moment donné ne restera en politique que
des médiocres donc c'est à dire que des
gens qui sont qui sont prêts à ça pour
continuer à être élu et ça je le dis à
nos concitoyennes et concitoyens à force
d'être dur quelquefois parce que les
élus sont à portée de baffes vous êtes
député vous avez envers des bus local ce
que ce que vous avez noté m a dit je
suis analyse je suis obligé d'abréger un
petit peu ce que vous voulez vous dire
c'est qu'on dégoûte mais bon ça c'est ce
que voulait nous dire on dégoûte les
bons de rester en politique à partir
mots ils sont confrontés oui sans
feindre une fausse humilité sans feindre
une fausse humilité oui alors c'est
parfois vous dit les autres se barre
mais ce bar et comme on dit on veut
passer dans la vie active vie
professionnelle dans le privé c'est pas
toujours facile
à moins de se livrer au pantouflage
quand on est ministre on va accueillir
ce team jourdain pour comprendre en quoi
consiste ce pantouflage est qui et qui
ça peut concerner quelqu'un un joli mot
déjà le pantouflage à l'origine c'est de
l'art gosset désigne fait prend aux
fonctionnaires de quitter le service de
l'état pour aller bosser dans une
entreprise privée la raison est souvent
très simple plus d'argent plus
d'opportunités parfois une meilleure
position sociale exemple typique et
récent de pantouflage mathieu en
politique l'ancien secrétaire d'état aux
transports jean baptiste djebbar il a
pris la tête d'opium un fabricant de
voitures hydrogène pour lui le
pantouflage pas de problème écouter le
venait du privé et je fais partie de
cette génération qui s'est engagé en
politique aux côtés d'emmanuel maquereau
en 2017 j'ai eu la chance d'être député
pour un peu plus de deux ans donc du
gouvernement pendant trois ans et puis
effectivement quand vous êtes membre du
gouvernement vous pouvez tout à fait
retourner dans le privé sous réserve de
respecter certaines règles et c'est ce
que c'est ce que j'ai fait alors j'ai
choisi jean baptiste djebbar et pour
illustrer mon propos mais on aurait pu
prendre d'autres exemples il ya brune
poirson cadre chez veolia députés mme
acronis secrétaire d'état la transition
écologique et qui avant même la fin de
son mandat décidé de rejoindre le groupe
accor elle exerce aujourd'hui au sein du
géant hôtelier la fonction de directrice
du développement
durable et le pantouflage ça ne concerne
pas seulement la macro ni évidemment
d'en trouve à gauche chez les
socialistes après ses fonctions de
ministre du travail n'est rien elle
connerie a par exemple décidé de
rejoindre un groupe de courtage en
assurances à droite il ya françois
baroin ancien ministre du budget sous
nicolas sarkozy certains voyaient en lui
un futur président de la république
raté il a choisi une autre route depuis
janvier il est à la tête de la filiale
française de la banque barclay's alors
le pantouflage c'est quand vous l'avez
dit c'est quand on quitte des fonctions
publiques pour passer à des fonctions
privées c'est encadré par la loi comment
oui ce qui dérange dans tout ça c'est
pas le passage du public au privé le
problème c'est qu'un homme ou une femme
de pouvoir se fasse embauchés dans le
privé pour pouvoir ensuite utiliser
éventuellement ses réseaux ses
connaissances son influence au service
d'une entreprise pour peser sur la
fabrication de la loi une loi qui doit
théoriquement se fabriquer dans
l'intérêt du plus grand nombre et non
dans l'intérêt dans certains intérêts
particuliers le code pénal il encadre
ces pratiques c'est l'article
432-13 il puni de trois ans
d'emprisonnement le fait pour un
ministre de passer dans une entreprise
qui a été dans sa sphère d'influencé
lorsqu'il était au gouvernement une
institution est chargée de contrôler
c'est passage du public au privé c'est
la haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique et les président et
mathieu par l'ancien socialiste didier
migaud alors on va de conclure cette
émission tout à l'heure en parlant d
éternel retour de ceux qui les éternels
revenant dans la vie politique mais
juste avant jeannette bougrab pour
rebondir là dessus est ce qu'il faut
favoriser les passerelles entre la
politique et le secteur privé ou le
monde professionnel on n'a que des
professionnels de la profession non
yahya baya il ya des professionnels la
profession des gens qui ont commencé en
militant dans les partis politiques où
le syndicalisme étudiant et qui ensuite
sont des en gros des apparatchiks du
parti qu'ensuite on ne peut pas apte à 6
temps parlementaire ensuite
parlementaire et ensuite un jour
ministre mais ce qui est le vrai
problème aujourd'hui et j'ai pas regardé
sur les origines sociologique il faut il
faut des gens qui soient en dehors de la
fonction publique parce que c'est vrai
que la possibilité de faire de la
politique c'est aussi de prendre des
risques et moi ça me choque pas que des
gens des ied en privé le problème c'est
sociologiquement quand vous regardez en
fait la composition
que ce soit de l'assemblée nationale ou
du sénat peut-être moins du sénat
d'ailleurs ou des mini c'est ils ont une
origine sociale ou une origine
professionnelle qui est assez homogène
il faut pas uniquement que ce soit des
hauts fonctionnaires qui ont fait des
nappes etc et ça c'est un vrai problème
alors évidemment vous allez dire que je
sais je suis trop bien aimé enfin je
suis vieille donc ses raisons mais
madame honorine d'un bérégovoy ça fait
rêver de ces gens qui viennent en
réalité quand une sorte d'écho de la
banque leur il était
doux et ça les gens exceptionnels
d'avoir les mêmes profils de se dire
parce qu'effectivement il ya un filet de
sécurité quand on est fonctionnaire on
peut revenir donc des gens qui ont alors
on reproche à ces personnes d'avoir été
d'aller dans le privé vous aurait
préféré qu'ils allaient enfin au chômage
qui fasse rien qui tombe dans la
dépression qu'enfin moi ça ne me gêne
pas voilà il ya une autorité qui
contrôlent voilà moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est qu'effectivement gay des
possibilités quand vous êtes dans une
entreprise qu'on puisse permette le
retour dans l'entreprise ça ce serait
intéressant ça permettrait de vérifier
un peu le vivier si j'ose dire
guillaume on va parler des revenants des
retours du mythe de l'éternel retour et
on va parler d'un des plus célèbres
d'entre eux en 2013 françois hollande a
répondu un enfant qui l'interrogé à
propos nicolas sarkozy battu le reverra
plus c'était loupé ça a pris plus grand
que la vue en tout cas oui parce que
fait timmer nicolas sarkozy jusqu'il ya
peu c'était quand même celui qui à
droite fallait continuer d'aller voir à
quelques kilomètres d'ici rue de
miromesnil dans le 8e arrondissement de
paris et en même temps cette ombre qui a
longtemps plané sur la droite ça aussi
lourdement handicapé la droite parce que
ce mythe du retour potentiel même après
l'échec de la primaire 2016 s'empêcher
clairement on le voit aujourd'hui
l'émergence d'un nouveau leader et puis
aussi nicolas sarkozy a entretenu la
droite jérôme lavrilleux l'a sans doute
entendu dans cette fosse des faits d'une
certaine façon on entend encore
aujourd'hui est souvent son entourage à
nicolas sarkozy nous dire qu'il a
presque gagné en 2012 qu'à quinze jours
près finalement il aura gagné cette
élection présidentielle donc
effectivement dans cet état d'esprit eh
bien il n'y a pas de bilan si ya pas de
bilan il n'y a pas de changement du
logiciel intellectuelle de la droite et
on voit bien d'ailleurs que sur le plan
des idées depuis dix ans finalement là
la droite un peu toujours les mêmes
recettes la baisse des impôts moins
d'immigrés et puis le retour du karcher
valérie pécresse elle-même on a parlé
dans la campagne présidentielle mais
pour vous cette période où le fantôme
sarkozy planait est en train d'être
refermées j'ai le sentiment que ça c'est
un petit peu effectivement
n'est pas terminé mais on sent que cette
influence commencent à s'affaiblir ces
dernières semaines et ces derniers mois
déjà en raison de ses condamnations
judiciaires même si là aussi il a fait
appel et puis surtout ce qui a changé
beaucoup de choses c'est le non soutien
à valérie pécresse c'est assez
intéressant qu'on nous ait changé je
pense que henry l'a fait avec des
parlementaires de droite qui vous
raconte comment dans leur permanence les
militants sarkozystes purs et durs à rim
5 en main avec les livres de l'ancien
président sarkozy ils disent je vous les
rangs pour nous c'est un traître on ne
veut plus en entendre parler ça c'est
quelque chose qui pèse et c'est pas
qu'un sentiment parce qu'on le voit dans
les études d'opinion notamment dans le
baromètre ipsos il a perdu près de 20
points de popularité auprès des
sympathisants des républicains et c'est
probablement un maigre lot de
consolation pour valérie pécresse mais
elle a sans aucun doute rendu service au
prochain leader des républicains pour
qui la rue de miromesnil je pense ne
sera plus un passage obligé henri
rapidement les retours réussis
oui c'est sa demande et c'est
giscard giscard d'estaing qui perd la
présidentielle hyper l'elysée qu'est ce
qu'il fait il fait tout le chemin à
l'envers alors après avoir
une espèce d exil temporaire au canada
en grèce où il a dans les rocheuses oui
oui il a ressassé un petit peu son échec
mais qu'est-ce qui fait sitôt rentré en
france il refait tout le chemin à
l'envers conseiller général conseiller
régional député président de parti et
avec un rêve de se représenter à la
paire française ça y jouera parce que la
guerre les guerres intestines sont les
plus fortes au sein des mêmes familles
politiques à droite notamment chirurgie
scar chirac balladur sarkozy chirac
enfin bref là bas ils vous en savez
quelque chose et cesse et c'est là que
c'est le plus dur et puis leur arrivée
maintenant la présence européenne et ça
marchera pas donc non les retours c'est
d'ailleurs en est le seul pays en
réalité où les crocodiles revient ainsi
quand vous regardez aux états unis
notamment ou dans d'autres pays parce
qu'on pourrait d'ailleurs de carrière on
perd en vérité alors je voudrais refaire
le tour tous les trois vous vous allez
revenus vont revenir en politique vous
conseillez vous conseiller un député du
rhône jérôme briot mais je ne suis pas
le député est loin de moi cette idée
saugrenue non non je reviens pas en
politique j'ai été j'ai fait 17 ans de
mandat quand même conseiller général et
député européen j'étais jamais j'ai
jamais été battu et à chaque fois le ch
était commandeur sa principale contre le
front national j'ai jamais été battu
mais je reviens pas en politique
je vais en décevoir peut-être un ou deux
je vais en rassurer sans doute beaucoup
je ne reviens pas en politique après
votre émission je prends mon tgv je
retourne en dordogne du ménage à faire
demain parce que j'ai des arrivées dans
les gîtes mais il s'avère que c'est une
histoire assez sympathique c'est que
j'ai un ancien stagiaire est élu député
m'a demandé si je pouvais l'aider je le
fais je voulais juste vous dire pour
terminer avec un sourire tout est dit
dans la folie des grandeurs avec de
funès qu'est ce que je vais devenir je
ne sais rien faire j'étais ministre ma
vie et ça c'est une angoisse sur naître
un certain et c'est une mauvaise
angoisse rasé vadi rapidement pour
conclure vous avez envie de revenir en
politique un jour
aujourd'hui non ici et si je devais y
revenir je ne voudrais surtout pas y
revenir par la politique mais plutôt
parce que je fais aujourd'hui c'est à
dire je conseille aujourd'hui compris
des gouvernements des organisations y
compris à l'étranger dans la question
des transitions urbain c'est
non pas par un parcours d'apparatchiks
c'est ça que vous c'est ça c'est ça
jeannette bougrab moi j'écris des livres
je trouvais que c'était mon dernier
livre sur sa lagarde au yémen la visite
en ce moment 2 mb z qui auront des âmes
et qui commet des crimes de guerre et
dans une guerre dont on parle pas parce
qu'il ya plus de quatre cent mille morts
je prépare un documentaire sur les
mutilations génitales puisque le combat
sur la question du droit des femmes ce
que les gens ne le voient pas mais il ya
une augmentation de l'excision en france
et qu'on n'en parle pas et c'est
justement public sénat qui en aucun cas
accepter en tout cas d' être le
diffuseur de ce documentaire est celle
dont on ne peut aussi avoir des
engagements et les porter sans faire
forcément de la politique au terme
classique du terme c'est la fin de ce
débat c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous quatre avoue 5 d'y avoir
participé
merci à vous de l'avoir regardé